If you haven't seen Avengers: Infinity War
yet, you might not want to stick around for
the rest of this video because we're about
to talk about the many casualties of the film
and how Avengers 4 may or may not deal with
those losses.
Consider yourself warned about spoilers ahead!
"Ready?"
"Let's go."
Marvel fans might still be reeling from all
the ashes-to-ashes-style action in Infinity
War, but as anyone who's read the Infinity
Gauntlet comic series knows, the Time Stone
can undo a lot of that damage if only someone
besides Thanos could get ahold of that glove.
Besides, it sounds like some of the lives
lost in the film still won't be undone in
Avengers 4.
In the emotional aftermath of Infinity War,
screenwriters Christopher Markus and Stephen
McFeely made it clear that not all the heartbreak
and tragedy fans saw in Infinity War will
be cleared away in the follow-up and that
fans shouldn't expect to know what'll happen
in the fourth film, either.
Markus told Buzzfeed,
“[Avengers 4] doesn’t do what you think
it does.
It is a different movie than you think it
is.
Also…[the deaths are] real.
I just want to tell you it’s real, and the
sooner you accept that, the sooner you will
be able to move on to the next stage of grief.”
Of course, there are some characters who still
seem safe for resurrection, considering Spider-Man,
Black Panther, and the Guardians of the Galaxy
have all got stand-alone sequels to star in,
despite being reduced to dust in the last
few minutes of Avengers: Infinity War.
But perhaps Markus is hinting at something
else here.
Maybe the demises that were less mystical
in Infinity War might be permanent, like with
Heimdall, Loki, Gamora, and Vision.
So, even if it seems like a few fan-favorites
might make a comeback, audiences should at
least be prepared for some of the Infinity
War goodbyes to be kinda forever.
Meanwhile, McFeely added that even though
Infinity War is a "fairly mature movie for
a blockbuster," fans should also prepare themselves
for even more intensity in Avengers 4, explaining:
"It's got a lot of fun in it, obviously, but
boy, it gets very mature.
The second one is also mature.
We're going to own these choices, and hopefully
surprise and delight you and get you invested.
It's by the same studio, the same filmmaking
team.
They were written at the same time, shot at
the same time."
He added that while the two films are "clearly
connected," they are two independent movies
and not just one big two-part narrative, as
the first film seemed to set up.
In other words, these screenwriters are telling
us that Avengers 4 might not pick up exactly
where Infinity War left off and proceed in
the direction we think it will, to rescue
all our fallen heroes.
But with all the time-turning action that
may happen in the fourth film, even those
characters who might be lost for good could
get a few final cameos to ease our suffering.
We'll find out for sure when Avengers 4 launches
in 2019.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!